all right thank you thanks very much
well I'm kind of like a lightning rod
for awkwardness kind of an awkward rod I
just finds me I'll give an example well
first off I am the master at saying the
wrong thing to women accidentally okay I
mean wha good like black belt level okay
like I was doing karaoke at an
after-hours bar in Chicago where I used
to live right doing a stellar rendition
of oops I did it again like I nailed it
you know I mean like I was Britney right
so this girl comes up to me and she's
like hey that was really funny hi I'm
Sarah right comes up to me gives me
rhythm and I could have said any number
of things to make her like me and be my
friend or maybe more the night was young
but instead what my brain told my mouth
to say and my mouth was I screw it I
hate this guy too
what I literally said to a girl was
thanks a lot where do you live what's
the worst thing you can ever say to a
girl it's probably that look at how tall
I am in crowded bars I look like I'm
trying to chew on girls heads right
where do you live and I didn't say oh do
you live around here are we neighbors
that would have been acceptable no I
said where do you live where exactly do
you live what's the address
I'm gonna hang out in the closet without
a shirt and a viking helmet honk your
boobies check out my balls okay
I didn't do the last two things but it
would not have been creepier if I had it
wouldn't have been creepy if I was
carrying rope and freaking duct tape
when I said that where do you live all
of a sudden I have a humpback in a hook
for a hand
chloroform rag coming at you put her in
the van with the others why it's mostly
I guess a it's mostly because of the
drinking right the heavy drinking I
obviously do with the body shape like
this but I've actually I've had to cut
down just to improve my hangovers it's
the only reason only reason I'm cut down
on drinking at all but it's just because
if you notice how bad your hangovers get
in your 30s like once you hit 30 they're
brutal
in your 20s hangovers in your 20s you're
like a cartoon character there's a barn
that exploded you're singed but you're
okay not I mean like hangovers in your
20s it doesn't even have figures like oh
my god my head's on fire there's frogs
in my stomach
what'd I do last night all right right
in your 30s hangovers in your 30s you're
like I'm gonna have a stroke I think my
brain is squeezing itself my arms are
numb this is not good in your 20s you
make plans for your hangovers you're
like oh I'm not doing nothing except
eating a whole bag of family size
ruffles hey and be watching all the
Rockies every Rocky movie that's it and
your 30s you're like I think I'll go to
a food court so that someone will catch
me when I have the inevitable stroke I'm
going to have at 4 p.m. today without
question so I am single and I live alone
most of you guessed correctly well done
but I'm fine with it cuz I think I
honestly think being in long-term
relationships can make you stupid
especially if you're a guy like I was
talking to a married friend he's like so
do you live alone you do a lot of
cooking cook for yourself I'm like yeah
dummy and nuts not the 50s did you step
up episode of Mad Men what are you
talking about I cook for myself but I
didn't say that right didn't want to
confront him so I was just like well no
you feed a lot of hungry man dinners huh
right I don't they're made of salt don't
eat those but I didn't even say that I
didn't even say that I made a perfect
Freudian slip and accidentally said well
he lot of lonely man dinners Oh
lonely man dinners is what I said that I
hate which was dead on I eat a lot of
lonely man dinners which is what all TV
dinners should be called I want to see
the ad for lonely man brand TV dinners
just a lumberjack and a cabin by himself
looking out the window at a future he'll
never have with a tear running on his
rapidly graying beard he's like 32 it
shouldn't be gray right
and the theme song kicks in no need to
open the can grab yourself a lonely man
and then a far away shot of the cabin
and a single gunshot lonely man but they
say on the cabin a long time after the
shots you're like did he shoot himself
or the fireplace I don't know what
happened to lonely man lumberjack thank
you guys so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you